TRUMP USING EXTREMELY VULGAR
.
STSA MSOHATEADNGIG
ATEEN.OMHAASNG AGRSMP UIL.OM US
SCIY, S WOWT.SN  FTIN
ASG ETMTHNEUL H
M
GSTHTPESEFOEOASISDOTUAN A T JNEE
MMP
OU JY,OTT'OF  T XTE  TRA H TBOS
MET I,NYATLEIEMELYAYPORIAIIPLTI
TAI A K LUSHEHE  I
].SYFEEAL OTI
ASLOHEUTFR A ANTVA
WTH TIOMESNT I UINTH W DLI
GH H>>D BINSTLLTHAEEDRKOU>> YIKR
REFERGMMRYPEAVAPOKTH.LKEHETA BHE
INT'TRA ETEE TNE TYSEAACEMLIET R
TR TKI  HONTTAN WNKINHYINHENNTSF
ERIGOPS INREF HD ?.NE  L IWHAHEI
LECUCS>> NY AOM R PRALESOG ER
UEAIVIFOITITO
AMEFOAB AET DOOWIN W IHE PRA
LSSOTNSNMACIAKRAOL HAHANDINND
INEISI LLNTONREOUIT
K,IT
LOL
EERKESINM,DITG GNG DNGY NMO,  YW
O
WNHE AOMO K S OSEIODI
H
TIHAEDBOETNOHEF S RA
HEER'TCSTHATH CUSEUT HIW,EEVE TS
N'HE DRY. OVID
M C T YOEINER